THE.
>> Dave: DOWN TO FORSBERG AND
THE SENA
ONCE, THAT WAS IN EARLY
DECET TO BUILD UP THE20-GOAL CA.
JUST RECENTLY BACK IN THEIR
LINEUP, 15 WITH A A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER, JOSH PURSUIT,
CREATING TURNOVERS, THIS WENT I.
>> Dave:T RIP, AND HOW HE
HELPED HIM PROGRESS.
>> Dave: PLAYED IN 15 OF 19 IN
EVER THREE-POINT GAME.
UP BY STEPHENSON OFF. BY FORSBE.
ONLY ALLOWED FIRST PERIOD GOALS
IN THEIR LAST FORAND HE TAKESSWS
LEGS.
THERE IS THE SAVE AND THETRYINGT
CHABOT AND OFF THE BACK
THIRD PERIOD, STATE THE OTTAWA .
AND DEFLECTED WIDE.
NOW PAUL CHASING AFTER IT.
LOOSE PUCK.HE HAD LEHNER MOVINGH
A STRONG THE DROP PASS TO OUT OF
THE AIRAYHEM
MOMENT, GREAT STOPLY THIRD,
SHOTS IN FAVOR OF OTTAWA.
STUTZLE, KOLESAR RUNS IT THE GAR
KEEGAN KOLESAR, NICE
PACIORETTY'S SHOT SIDE,
HIS THIRD OF THE SEASON